thank you very much the thank you for
the introduction and thank you Trisha my
wife who works with me and is also an
author right here we know about
Hillsdale we've read about it we have
followed we've been online and over the
years we've seen what this college does
we understand that it's one of the last
places in America where you can get a
classical education what we didn't
appreciate is how vibrant this community
was in this college is until we actually
got here so it is amazing I grew up on
debate I was on debate in high school
and in college it's what I always engage
in it's what I thought you you had a bad
idea from somebody you got rid of the
idea by engaging it in the Public Square
and showing why it was wrong and we have
trouble doing that nowadays in the in
this country and so it's fantastic to be
here I think everybody at Hillsdale has
made it possible and I thank you for
being here me
[Applause]
so yes this is some of the Pharma is not
here but don't worry we're talking about
Pharma these are books Trisha and I have
done over a period of time I'm
particularly proud of why America slept
because it was the story that showed how
the CIA and the FBI missed all of the
warnings for 9 11. and why 911 didn't
have to happen and you knew that you hit
a nerve when it was published and they
started to come after you as they do and
said no that's all wrong the Saudi book
secrets of the Kingdom were proud of
because we both got banned from entering
the Kingdom so that was good that was a
good reason not to go there
um and uh God's Bankers I was I'm raised
Catholic I went to Sisters of Charity
for grammar school and uh and Jesuits
for high school and this is the story
200 year history of the Vatican and the
pope cannot tell us in enough ways no
when we try to get access to the secret
archives so we are still failing to do
that but we we have a lot of fun we like
to pick topics that we think there's
something new on so when I went to my
publisher and said what about a history
of the American pharmaceutical industry
they said you're crazy and then I said
no I think I can do it and five years
later we turned in a manuscript and it
was and it was interesting to do what
I'm going to talk about tonight is in
part the opioid crisis but to get to the
opioid crisis you need a little bit of
background in history about what I call
the DNA of Pharma what makes the
American pharmaceutical industry
different than just about anybody
anything else that you have
um one of the things by the way on
Pharma when it was finally reviewed on
different journals you'll notice a word
came up that my publisher hated because
they say nobody buys an encyclopedia
people buy a page Turner but reviews
would say an encyclopedic book and they
would just say oh no why did we publish
this book but actually for a writer
that's always a good thing to see the uh
now one of the things about the American
drug industry it doesn't start we think
of it today as this industry that's so
large that uh it's always been like this
but it actually starts in the middle of
the 19th century around the time of the
Civil War and why because there's a
tremendous demand for morphing
morphine's one of the few things that
people know works and it ends up working
to um to stop pain and there's a need
for it so some people decide to get into
the business so there are these two
German cousins uh there they are Charles
Earhart and Charles Pfizer they have 2
500 in savings and thousand dollar loan
and a year into the Civil War they
establish a plant in New York and they
are manufacturing just high quality
morphine and that's enough business to
start Pfizer and its growth to what it
is today
Edward Robinson Squibb he was a naval
wartime surgeon he threw adulterated
morphine over board when it arrived that
was bad when he was actually in the
Civil War and later knew the demand for
Quality morphine and ended up creating
that company together with his two sons
some of you might be familiar with two
pharmacist Brothers in Philadelphia John
and Frank Wyeth same thing Civil War
morphine is their first initial product
that they're putting out about 70
percent of their sales end up coming
from that drug alone the um a chemist
and a union army colonel Eli Lilly he
missed he knew the importance of
morphine and good quality drugs because
he served in the Civil War he tried to
open his company Eli Lilly
um a year left on the Civil War but he
didn't make it he opened up just at the
end still it was a painkiller that was
his seller for the first 10 years that
Lily was up and running Bristol Meyer
same thing John Myers and William
Bristol two investors of put up five
thousand dollars each to buy a drug firm
they renamed as their own they did also
have a good seller they had a mineral
salt that was supposedly a pain reliever
but morphine was still their number one
seller and if you think it's not just
all the names Harvey Park was a minor
turned investor George Davis was a 27
year old salesman
their big hit morphine carried them for
about three decades in 1900 they
patented a drug
called adrenaline and it's an actual
part of our body and other companies
that oh by the way you can't you can't
uh patent that and they won a court case
so every other company that has an
adrenaline product has to call it
epinephrine so Oni Park Davis could call
it actually at that time adrenaline and
the last ones are Silas Burroughs a
pharmacist and Henry welcome he was a
promoter who claimed to have invented
invisible ink it was just actually a
formula of lemon juice that disappeared
slowly it wasn't very good but they did
much better with their firm you look at
these names it's quite interesting
because these aren't just names that we
have forgotten about these are the names
that existed and have grown over the
time to be in the top 10 of the
pharmaceutical industry they started in
a business at a time with an addictive
product granted but one of the few that
worked and why do I say one of the few
that worked this time
doctors knew very there wasn't even an
AMA doctors knew very little about what
caused disease illnesses infections so
it was a time that I call the Cocaine
Cowboys day of the American
pharmaceutical industry there goes I
think the cover on the mic but it's
still working
um
anything went you could have a uh they
were called Pat and drugs so morphine
was available opium was allowed mixtures
with alcohol uh the a couple of these
products these were the big sellers uh
for a 30 and 40 year period louder than
was marketed by a whole series of
companies that was a tincture of opium
coating and morphine well you think that
oh by the way it's not enough to have
opium uh we'll give them a little
coating as well I still don't look like
they fall asleep how about morphine on
top of that all three it's amazing more
people didn't die Dr Seth's Arnold's
cough killer that's fantastic it was
about 30 percent morphine that'll stop
your cough
um then Mariana
about that noise
better
all right sorry
um Vin Mariana is a was done by a French
chemist it was a number one seller for a
while in the 1870s uh it was restored
energy and vitality turned out that that
was red wine with 7.2 milligrams per
ounce of cocaine
I kid you not this was the
pharmaceutical Industries Mrs Winslow 65
milligrams of morphine and a fluid mixed
with alcohol and a little bit of ammonia
water now the biggest seller this was
the one that everybody wanted to get was
cups baby's friend this was what you
gave to your child so it wouldn't be
colic it wouldn't cry at night it would
just be a good baby it turns out that it
and what they did they were very very
smart they went ahead and checked the
birth announcements and newspapers to
find out when mothers had new babies and
then they sent them a sample and then
they would sell them the product in fact
it was opium it did cause deaths and
eventually their business went down
the middle is one of my personal
favorites the Amazon of its day was of
course the Sears and Roebuck catalog and
they sold for a dollar fifty a small
vial of cocaine and a hypodermic so that
you could be able to buy that so it's
pretty remarkable to me
the now
my Trisha's personal favorite is bear
the the reason I say that is Bayer was a
real pharmaceutical company was selling
more prescriptions and more drugs than
anybody else in the world and over a
five-year period their scientists
invented found four different class of
drugs they found acetaminophen that was
the first in 1897 pretty interesting so
Tylenol and then they discovered Bayer
Aspirin a couple of years later true
wonder drug aspirin can be fantastic and
then in 1900 they actually had
discovered before that heroin which they
patented after the German name hirosh
for and they called it heroin and that's
how it was sold in the U.S as
any of you guess a cure for morphine
addiction the that's pretty good that's
true true I kid you not and they
invented an entire new class of drugs
with barbiturates luminol was their
first product and then when they
marketed in the United States they
marketed as phenobarbital
all without prescriptions because you
didn't need a prescription you're 18
years of age you can walk into any
pharmacy you could walk out with any of
these drugs
however Bayer
scientist said one of these drugs is too
dangerous to Market
we've done tests on animals of that and
it looks like it has a high toxicity
level so they didn't put one of them out
you know which one Tylenol acetaminophen
was never marketed because they thought
that was too dangerous but no problem
with the heroin and the barbiturates I
mean the
and
this is a just a quick side note
even Bayers drug companies can sometimes
hide things they don't like Arthur
eichengroon who's the top of the picture
there
he was the chief of pharmaceutical
science he was responsible for the
discovery of acetaminophen and aspirin
47 patents to his credit Bayer did this
massive 2 000 page Tome the official
history of Bayer in 1934 a year after
Hitler had become the chancellor in
Germany and they had already aryanized
their company and kicked all the Jews
out so they didn't give credit to
eichengroon they gave it instead to his
assistant the man in the lower part a
good Aryan Dr Hoffman well eichengroon
complained about that and said I was the
person responsible for discovering those
two drugs and they sent him to a
concentration camp he lived he got out
in 1948 he died he got out on 45 but he
died in 48. it took until 1999 for a
Scottish pharmacologist to actually
track down the story and be able to
publish it and give him the credit that
he was due after all those years it's a
little side story that I happen to like
justice comes but sometimes is delayed
the uh
now these are the fellows the new
sheriff is in town Who start to change
the way things happen in the drug
industry this is Harvey Washington Wiley
and his bureau of chemistry and Wiley is
the person here if this works you might
see him if I can get this to work
possibly right there that is Harvey
Washington Wiley he's the son of an
itinerant preacher
he goes to Washington that is the entire
1900 Bureau of chemistry doesn't look
like a typical government bureaucracy we
see today huh the uh
and
that he was
from the very beginning interested in
going ahead and regulating
additives to food there was no
regulations on it he thought he could do
something about it and he was also
interested in what he might be able to
do on drugs but food was his major
design
he has a thing he he calls for
volunteers and he sets up a group called
the poison Squad by the the Press
and they are volunteers that dress up in
evening wear and he cooks them dinners
with his staff every night in the
basement of the chemistry the Department
of Chemistry and he puts additives like
Boron and formaldehyde and other things
into the food and he sees how sick they
get one of them eventually dies but he
learns a lot in that process and he
keeps going back to Congress trying to
get a bill passed and they say no no no
no no and everything as you know in
Congress is a bit of timing and so
finally we are sharing what I call the
progressive error in 1906 he gets his
law and it's the Pure Food and Drug Act
the uh and that's why these uh that he's
the driving force on it also helps uh by
the way that at that point
you you had a book done
um in in which for the first time you
really understand in the jungle
um you know how the meat packing was
done in Chicago and how terrible it was
people were outraged by that and it gave
some impetus to finally make the changes
in Congress
all the 1906 law did First Federal Law
regarding Food and Drugs was to say that
you have to put on the label what's
inside it doesn't have to be safe
doesn't have to be therapeutic doesn't
have to cure anything even if you claim
it does but you have to tell us what's
on the front and so the first major
lawsuit that Wiley brings after 1906 Act
is against Coca-Cola of all people he
says that's because you have caffeine in
the drink and you don't disclose that on
the label and you don't have Coca in the
drink and you say Coca-Cola
government lost that suit the um it
wasn't his finest moment unfortunately
in 1914
long after you know another eight years
later government passes the Harrison Act
and that bans all narcotics in the
country so all of a sudden the morphine
the Opium the codeine the heroin or the
the Cannabis the cocaines used in
thousands of patent drugs are out the
window